a fragment, that is, it must be plowed, probably
some kind of steel, I don’t know, there is
additional armor, the best thing is that the
tenant of the house
during the
potential air and
what
I had them at all,
he rushed another record, go
[music]
to us again, this is something
you know, you will say
this is a rocket
[music]
where the
practice of rhodis is
especially unique because of what unique and
special they could with slugs
of this city
[music]
our museum
from my practical score of 100 rocky
brought to 24 of the fierce museum is alive the museum
developed on the foundations to strongly
hostage to ukraine volumes of the soul great plans
for my life
[music]
breathe, even
fall asleep for a long time and then I left
closed the kilogram and the reality in it
came it is
very p  I left the gamut declare and the very
next day they took mine in the heading
will be engaged in building the dismantling of the
collection dismantling the expo go
swimming in this documentation, then such an
even lower group
will succeed, the shafts and mitts are scattered
to
this day, dogs are choking tolerantly
months for us, it comes with good
numbers
[music]
there is such a moment that those architects
who were of Ukrainian origin
built quite brightly and interestingly, and
the least known of them was probably
Miroshnichenko here actually
on Zhukovsky in the first place we
we consider Miroshnichenko’s work as
the front wing,
this is already after someone made
repairs from the housing office, but it was forty
years ago that they painted something after
and removed the turnip
, we usually talk about the entrance, this
beautiful front door scene in our
yard
[music]
naturally an integral part of every
historical  th house in Odessa, this is the door,
this is the entrance group,
which, in fact, like the face of the project, is what the
resident touches every day
[music],
but on February 4, we almost immediately
closed to work and do not
stop
to feel calm, it
brings us great relief, this is
work  not just paint stripping in
general restoration
of
19th century carpentry because to the sound of the sirens and to
all the pressing problems that we
faced, the
restoration of this ancient
product allows us to focus on
life focus on art
[music]
[applause]
we  all the
herbs and teenagers shiva while we were engaged in
language
documentaries, others could be we are dragging
so called a bucket and the holy account of the grass of
wine and then came this knows even
more than an insight to be considered an action
is called with the help of let the cabbage even the
halls of the museum
to the stock exchanges and find vidvidovaca types of stock exchanges
and run up did i do mad d&
g  t to such
personal personal whatever classical
skill
[music]
we of course believe that the
guests of the city will also
see this beauty that Odessa is
an open-air museum, whatever one may say, and
in fact if we go to the museum we see
paintings there in one  building, then here are all the
buildings that have these
paintings and I would like, of course, to
have enough life to open all
these paintings, to show
art to people so that they can
enjoy and believe that to
strengthen this belief that the
city is really historical, that
is, that it is Soviet  the union only
conserved all these murals that
are under layers of paint
they are destroyed and that it is possible to save this whole thing
to fix
[music] a
waste of a factory discus sneakers a story for
people tion soul more
to the point
I want you too Ukraine I
don't want to shoot I don't want Bunin to
knead people these are cultural monuments
I'm on the mind of a bath novice and over
Mr. [ __ ] log cabins you let in here we be I'm
beautiful such a style of work here such a
danagorn you will start with the goal
[music]
spadchyna the tragedy of the brigades and there to study
history then a man knowing his smoking
Otto chronology March 1 not history
you can set up shares of a
transcendental link with a sweetheart, then you
are in this like plans for my everyday life
[music]
and the visual form is that the
paint is being removed, some process is somehow
calming, there is some kind of faith
that everything will work out and  despite the fact
that something is being destroyed somewhere,
it is considered to destroy us all, we are here
locally
trying to open this story to show how everything
was then what people saw
120 describe 200 years ago
[music
] today we are on the board
saving our colleagues  thymus
manifested yet the vans turn up to
us on the sofa at a time and where they are with a fixed
eye in us we will decompose this we
can hp.  turn wither away the relics of the target it
will be yaku maybe soon the gestures of rich of
our museum at 24 can come true
at he brazenly didn’t hold we can
even
pull the line at the tu-tu
line Shahu david will be cotton wool
new ukraine for a new model of
our first of ours with the crimea to the donbass
[music  ]
[music]